the giants are celebrating
juneteenth today and they are wearing a
replica uniform of the old
san francisco sea lions marking the 75th
anniversary of the west coast
negro baseball association team on the
hill today for the giants will be
alex wood six and three with a three
seven one era lifetime
against the phillies three and three
with a three three six era
they hit the right field he hit it right
on the ground and hit it very
hard and right through on that breaking
ball from alex wood
so one out herrera still at first here
is real muto
is swung on and fouled tipped into the
mid of posey strike three
93 mile an hour fastball big moment here
the phillies had the bases loaded with
two down and the rookie
boom trying to put him ahead
[Applause]
that hit him and the appeal
to the first base up cry for the swing
and greg gibson said no he didn't swing
so that's a run alec baum with a
two-strike count gets hit by the pitch
to force in
oh double herrera one-nothing phillies
it's one nothing philly's base is loaded
and now luke williams gets a shot now
it's a full count
and it's popped up solado
getting over through all of that the
phillies get
just the one run and for aaron nolan
five and four three six nine era a lot
of pitchers would take that but aaron
hasn't been satisfied with
with the way he's pitched so far this
season wade hits a base hit into right
field
so another hit for lamont wave junior to
start the game
one nothing phillies but here come the
giants mike kistremski comes up now
against aaron nola
hit hard deep center field way back
there
it's gold a two run homer
for yostransky two to one giants
they get a fastball it's just really
right out there belle high on the
outside part of the plate
they have a runner at first and a guy
who hit his 10th home run of the year
last night coming to the plate brandon
belt
and there's a ground ball right side
it's picked by williams they'll spin
throw to second one on the first double
play
wow four six three nicely done for luke
williams who just keeps moving around
the diamond like where's waldo
now brandon crawford and the pitch swing
gonna miss he got him breaking ball and
crawford goes down on strikes but the
giants
take the lead two down back to the top
of the order oh dubo herrera
one and two to odubal herrera into the
defense
from right field the throw pulls belt
off the bag
oh dubo herrera racing up the line and
solano had to come rushing in from right
field had to hurry that throw and he
pulled him off
yeah that that's a tough one especially
as a second baseman for the phillies see
if they could take advantage of it if
you're alex would
how can you get yourself out of this
ending with two outs donovan solano
keeps the inning going for the powerful
reese
hoskins that's a blast to left field
that's headed for berkeley up near the
top of the bleachers
wow two run homer for hoskins
and the phillies jump right back ahead
and no one right now feels worse than
donovan solano up there
just round ball routine round ball you
figure you're out there
extend it reece hoskins made the giants
pay fosler to second
jugger to third and that'll bring up
lamont wade junior
the giants are 15 and three this year
when he's been in the starting lineup
that's a base hit down the right field
line
duggar scores the tying run and foster
the go-ahead run
wade digging for second it's a double
and the giants are back ahead
these batters look mighty hitterish
they're taking advantage of every
mistake
the other kitchen has thrown so here is
yasremski who hit a long two-run homer
427 feet
pop fly this one is falling
falling it's in there
just a pop-up that nobody could get to
wade scores third rbi
for yaz and it is five to three giants
going to the third inning will be harper
mccutchen and baum do a pitch to harper
and a swinging the ground ball back
towards the middle of the diamond it's
deflected by wood
and that'll just keep it out of the
reach of brandon crawford harper
hustling
heading for second and he will get there
and harper with a little
fire on the bases now gets second on a
ground ball up the middle
first two hitters on for the phillies as
they look for an answer back
that makes it through it hit the side of
the mound harper in the score
and the phillies are coming right back
five to four giants
one out second and third alex wood
thinking about a way out of this with
the
ronald teres the batter up 1-0 pitch and
a swing of the drive well hit center
field deep going back on it is duggar he
can't get it
it'll land on the warning track and go
all the way to the wall two runs are
going to score
on the double by ronnie torreas and the
phillies are back
in front as back and forth we go it's
6'5
philadelphia we're going to the bottom
of the third the giants trail
six to five granted belt will lead off
against erin nola here
there's a long shot this one is headed
for san francisco bay
it is white and the game is
tied just like that six to six
the craziness continues you don't use
the term that much in baseball the lead
has changed hands
three times already and we're only in
the third inning the giants have tied
the game again
the tenth pitch of the sequence to
solano is ball four
that's all for aaron nola first time
this year that nola
has allowed as many as six runs and
there's only one out in the third inning
uh a one and it's hit sharply diving
thereas has it
what a play by ronnie thereas diving up
the middle snares that liner
just above the dirt belt takes the walk
crawford the hitter
2-2 and they got belt picked off belt
ran and then the throw goes to hopkins
when he drops the ball
belt just kept on going which is smart
and reece hoskins
went to go throw and drop the ball so
instead of an out
belt is at second with still only one
away
pick off at second and goes into center
field
trace breaking in behind him and they
might have picked him off on a good
throw
they
struck him out high fastball got him 95
on that one from suarez
and desperate for a strikeout there and
ranger gets it there's the second out
and a swing at a fly ball left center
field fairly deep mccutchen drifting
back to the track nearing the wall he
makes the catch right up against the
padded fence
steve kepler deciding to go with harleen
garcia here
in the sixth against ronald torrez
that ball is crushed deep left center
field
and that ball is gone torreyas
the littlest guy in the field has just
muscled up
his second home run of the year and the
phillies
are for the fourth time in this game
back ahead
phillies are back on top it's a three
rbi game for the reyes who's got a homer
and a double
it looks like matt bierland is going to
make his a big league debut as a pinch
hitter he's the pitch the veiling rips
one toward the right side it's a base
hit
into right field and matt bierling with
his first major league hit
and the phillies celebrate that in the
dugout they want the baseball
new pitcher into the game zach littell
for the giants rhys hoskins will be the
batter there goes the runner
posey's throw and in the dirt and
knocked down
by solano and it's a steal severely
runner at second now for the fills for
the big part of this yard
[Applause]
the wind carries it and slater who i
think thought he was going to get it
could not catch up to it and feeling
around to score
on a double that would have been a home
run in
most ballparks without question four
hoskins
eight to six phillies now the bases are
loaded
one out here comes odubal herrera
on the run the tag at third balm heading
home
the throw and he just beats it and it is
nine to six phillies
two outs runners at first and second for
reese hoskins
deep left center field way back there
and gone another home run
for reese hoskins and he's going off
here today in san francisco
and the phillies break it open they now
lead it 12-6
a six rbi day for reese hoskins
two men on only one man out here comes
williams
the pitch swung on and ripped down the
left-field line that's in for a base hit
and andrew mccutchen around third he'll
come home to score out of chrome will be
held at third base and luke williams
with an rbi
double and the phillies now lead it 13-6
we are going to the bottom of the ninth
david hale looking to get the final out
it's lamont wade jr
a miss he struck him out of the ball
game is over huge day for reese hoskins
to lead the way
as the phillies pummel the giants this
afternoon in san francisco
13-6